for four days every year in the darkness
of winter the river streets and
buildings of Leo are turned into a
dazzling festival of lights it's great
there's so much to discover only you
knew we're from Leon so we used to it
it's always great the festival is great
it's our first but we really love it it
allows us to get some fresh air and see
some wonderful things featuring over 80
light installations the dazzling display
is the biggest of its kind in europe
this time Berlin light designer
Christopher boda is taking part he and
his team are responsible for lighting up
the Otay division the regional
government building a sob I've MacLeish
working with light darkness and light
has always been a fascination of mine
Men's top quality as humans were
conditioned to pay attention to light
and movement and we're all so fascinated
by it and I hope that comes across in
our installation four days before the
festival boda arrived to begin
programming his spectacle it consists of
50 illuminated triangles suspended above
ground a marriage of motion and music
renowned electronic musician wilbert
hanko worked on the soundtrack I'll be
multi we have light elements that run on
different motors we have 150 individual
motors and 50 light elements that means
everything has to work perfectly a
single fault in the system would cause
big problems it was a few streets away
french designer Jean Shia dacosta bajic
is testing his installation he's in
charge of lighting Leon's Town Hall
cassini p buku burner it's brought me a
lot of joy it's an important project for
me and one that required a lot of
preparation I had to travel to Leon four
or five times luckily I have family here
but I really enjoy the work especially
with so many talented people taking part
in working for the city was w naveen the
festival of lights and leo has a long
tradition it started about a hundred and
sixty years ago with a procession of
lanterns and candles in honor of the
Virgin Mary his ideas the origins of the
festival make it special it's anchored
deeply in the history of the city in
1850 to city officials and religious
leaders decided to honor the Virgin Mary
they wanted to erect a statue of her
next to the Basilica it was supposed to
happen on the eighth of September but
the weather was terrible iconia an ATT
break so the people of Leon decided to
push back the date a few months that's
why December the 8th has since been the
day commemorated with a light procession
through the city this year's event has
attracted about 3 million people the
highlights include the projections on
the plastic a hole and an installation
in a two kilometer long highway tunnel
hundreds of visitors have been gathering
to watch Costa fo bodas contribution
Dean select the installation is working
we haven't had any big problems so far I
think it's breathtaking Scott guess the
nuts on moment last night there was a
moment when I stood in front of it and
thought is that that's just incredible
it doesn't happen often with my own work
the festival of lights always finds ways
to reimagine and reinvent itself seeing
tradition not as a constraint but as a
strength to build on